[Musique]
le moteur non mais c'est pas possible
alors là c'est fort on peut avoir
parfois l'impression que les économistes
disent n'importe quoi et avec les crises
économiques tout particulièrement
lorsque les choses vont mal leur
crédibilité intellectuelle est atteinte
leurs déclarations de passer sont
épluchés et malheurs tous ceux qui
n'avaient pas vu venir la catastrophe
bourg-en-bresse
le problème ne tient pas à l'économiste
met à la discipline
je suis romain et vous êtes sûr mais
l'idée de culture générale
[Musique]
alors tout d'abord qui yehia bref c'est
un économiste américain décédé en 2006
qui est connu pour avoir fait partie du
brain trust du président américain john
fitzgerald kennedy
ce groupe de conseillers qui appartenait
à l'élite intellectuelle et académies
des états unis mais aussi pour avoir
conceptualiser la capacité des
entreprises à dicter aux consommateurs
leurs désirs normale et aussi
l'émergence d'une classe de gestionnaire
et managers et enfin pour avoir écrit
deux bons ouvrages de vulgarisation
économiques notamment sur la crise de
1929 et sur l'argent meygal bresse c'est
surtout un économiste spéciale à deux
titres
et il était un économiste plutôt
littéraire au le sens où il se méfiait
beaucoup de la mathématisation de la
discipline et c'est aussi pour ça que je
les aime bien galbraith était aussi
spécial parce qu'il était très critique
à l'égard de l'économie
d'après lui il y aurait des énoncés qui
persiste au sein de la discipline qui
sont encore véhiculée est encore en
seigner malgré l'évidence de leur
caractère mensonger
dans ce petit essai intitulé les
mensonges de l'économie il affirme que
les intérêts financiers le prestige
intellectuel brouille la réalité écrit
un décalage entre d'une part les idées
admises dans la discipline et d'autre
part la réalité voici donc quels sont
selon lui les sept plus gros mensonge de
l'économie vous allez voir que les
derniers vont vous étonner quand on veut
désigner le système économique des pays
industrialisés on ne parle plus très
souvent de capitalisme on dit plutôt
libre entreprise sociale démocratie ou
économie de marché
ce faisant pour galles bresse on gomme à
la fois le passé peu reluisant des
capitalistes et la puissance des grandes
entreprises grâce à la connotation
mélioratif des mots libre social mêmes
marchés en revanche le mot capitalisme
charrie avec lui
la prédominance des propriétaires et
l'asservissement des ouvriers l'idée de
monopole la dimension d'auto destruction
du système les crises et même selon la
presse leur responsabilité dans le
déclenchement des guerres ça fait
beaucoup mais surtout ce premier
mensonge et la source d'un deuxième
[Musique]
en parlant d'économie de marché plutôt
que de capitalisme on présuppose que le
système est comme une démocratie
économique où c'est le consommateur qui
aurait le pouvoir dans la mesure où il
imposerait ses désirs aux producteurs or
pour galles bresse rien n'est moins vrai
c'est en vérité le producteur qui
influencent et qui dirige la demande du
consommateur grâce au marketing
l'entreprise perçoit le consommateur de
choisir son produit
elle manipule pour faire naître un
nouveau besoin d'expression
de fait convaincre les consommateurs
grâce à de l'information ou grâce à du
divertissement
c'est devenu une opération banale pour
les entreprises mais c'est ignorer par
les économistes
du coup galles bresse dit qu'il n'y a
guère que dans les écoles de commerce
que l'économie est proche de la réalité
là je suis sûre à 200% qu'il n'a pas
fait une école de commerce
[Musique]
quoi de commun entre les tâches d'un
ouvrier dans une usine et la création
d'un tableau par un peintre
d'un côté c'est répétitif ingrat long et
épuisant etc et de l'autre ses créatifs
enrichissant et gratifiant et pourtant
on parle bien de travail dans les deux
cas ça pour galles bresse c'est de la
pure escroquerie alors l'expérience du
travail est certes différente selon les
personnes mais pour la grande majorité
de la population le travail c'est une
activité forcé par les nécessités les
plus primaires de l'existence c'est plus
précisément une obligation vitale pour
les pauvres tandis que les riches eux
s'en affranchissent et peuvent jouir du
loisir pour illustrer cette vérité
galles bresse reprend la citation de
caisse des mots gravé sur la pierre
tombale d'une femme de ménage ne me
pleurez pas mes amis ne me pleurez pas
jamais car je ne vais plus rien faire
pour l'éternité
la mort l'a libéré du travail
[Musique]
on assimile volontiers l'entreprise au
risque et à la libre initiative mais ce
sont surtout des caractéristiques des
pme et des entreprises familiales
or à partir d'une certaine taille
l'activité économique de l'entreprise
requièrent une gestion centralisée
c'est à dire une bureaucratie quand on
entend bureaucratie on pense urss dans
ma main abyei est sacrée
administration et ça le mec qui parle
tout seul mais tu vas faire la queue
comme tout le monde
mais c'était également une réalité de
l'entreprise comme le terme est connoté
péjorativement on parle plutôt de
management qui fait plus d année qu'est
ce qui fait marcher sa fille qu'est ce
qui fait marcher d'avis que ce qui fait
marcher
[Musique]
marché
mais qu'est ce qui vous fait marcher moi
ce marché avant l'heure d'un côté la
bureaucratie et bien sûr nocives
elle ralentit voire elle paralyse
l'action épuisé le temps à l'auto
expansion la bureaucratie appelle la
bureaucratie mais d'un autre côté est
bien nécessaire pour donner toute son
ampleur à l'innovation galbe récit la
bureaucratisation de l'entreprise à
l'inversion du rapport de force entre
propriétaires et directeurs
en dépit des apparences ce serait
désormais il écrit au début des années
2000 mais son intuition et antérieures
ce serait désormais les managers qui
aurait le pouvoir et non plus les
actionnaires
[Musique]
on oppose traditionnellement le secteur
privé et le secteur public
c'est notamment le cas en france où les
secteurs publics est important on
distingue bien les entités qui relève de
l'un est celle qui relève de l'autre on
associe volontiers certaines propriétés
à l'un et à l'autre
or pour galles bresse si on regarde les
choses sérieusement
en réalité la distinction publique
privée n'existe pas elle est de l'ordre
du discours pas du réel il donne
l'exemple du rôle très important du
secteur privé dans le secteur public aux
états unis l'influencent de l'industrie
de l'armement dans la politique
étrangère américaine par exemple
[Musique]
si servir à l'implication croissante des
mercenaires dans les guerres dans cet
hélicoptère au dessus de bagdad des
hommes qui font le coup de feu contre
des insurgés
ce sont d'anciens soldats engagés par
des sociétés militaires privées ce qu'on
appelle des contractors ou encore
l'impression qu'on peut avoir que de
grandes entreprises privées comme
notamment goldman sachs l arrivée de
barack obama de nombreux dirigeants de
goldman contre la maison blanche le
gouvernement et lorsque certains
deviennent les gendarmes des marchés
ça revient à nommer un renard pour
protéger le poulailler
mais aussi d'autres placent leurs pions
aux plus hauts postes de
l'administration fédérale américaine la
question est soulevée aussi en france où
les présidents pompidou est aujourd'hui
macron se sont vus reprocher d'être
passé par la banque rothschild
[Musique]
étant donné que des deux secteurs qui ne
sont donc en réalité pas du tout
imperméable étant donné que c'est
surtout les secteurs privés qui pénètre
le secteur public
cela introduit un biais cacher mais
important dans l'action publique pour
galles bresse les entreprises les plus
puissantes redéfinissent l'intérêt
public pourra l'adapter à leurs
capacités et à leurs besoins selon lui
la politique économique c'est à dire
l'action économique du gouvernement est
aux antipodes de l'intérêt économique
général
par exemple les réductions d'impôts
n'auraient pas l'effet de ruissellement
par lequel elles sont justifiées elles
ne bénéficierait pas aux plus
nécessiteux pour galles bresse il
faudrait plutôt encouragé directement la
consommation ce qui profiterait à tout
le monde
de même la protection de l'environnement
qui relèvent évidemment de l'intérêt
général puisqu'on habite tous la même
terre est négligée parce que les
entreprises les plus puissantes n'y
trouvent pas leur compte
à court terme mais l'exemple de
corruption de la définition de l'intérêt
public sur lequel galles bresse insiste
celle influence du complexe
militaro-industriel contre lequel le
président eisenhower avait mis en garde
les américains
oui mais en gros l'industrie de
l'armement tient l'armé laquelle
poussent en faveur du déclenchement de
la guerre afin d'écouler le stock da on
estime à environ 550 millions le nombre
d'armes à feu actuellement en
circulation
autrement dit il y a
un homme sur 12 qui est armé sur cette
planète la seule question c'est comment
armes et les 11 autres bah oui il faut
une bonne guerre pour vendre des armes
c'était pas ma guerre
[Musique]
dial bresse est assez cash la finance
est pour lui un univers bien connu pour
ses mensonges
le principal est selon lui la
prévisibilité de l'économie rien jeu
passera rien en fait comme la prévision
est une activité très appréciée et
rémunérés l'économiste a surtout envie
de faire plaisir à ses clients qui eux
espèrent tirer un profit de ces
prévisions et du coup l'intérêt
particulier supplante l'objectivité
scientifique l'espérance où le besoin
l'emportent sur la réalité dans les
faits explique diane bresse wall street
rémunèrent grassement des économistes
pour qu'il donne une allure sophistiquée
à l'ignorance générale gagnent presse
dénonce donc la situation de conflit
d'intérêts des économistes de la finance
situation qui les pousse à diffuser des
mensonges
[Musique]
je résume d'après ian bresse il existe
donc cette mythe ou mensonge si on veut
en économie l'existence d'une forme de
démocratie économique la souveraineté du
consommateur l'épanouissement par le
travail l'absence de bureaucratie dans
l'entreprise la distinction au secteur
privé secteur public l'intérêt public et
la rationalité des fondements de la
finance alors on peut reprocher à égal
bresse d'être un peu excessif en parlant
de mitu de mensonges
mais sur le fond ce qu'il avance me
semble très intelligent et très solide
après ce qu'un économiste pourrait lui
rétorquer c'est qu'il arrive forcément à
l'économie de dire des bêtises parce que
comme toute discipline qui se veut
scientifique
elle progresse vers la vérité par essais
et erreurs c'est à dire par correction
successifs l'adage latin dis bien errare
humanum est perseverare diabolicum
ce qui signifie l'erreur est humaine
c'est l'entêtement qui est diabolique
enfin pour ce qui est des situations de
conflit d'intérêts ce n'est pas un
problème propre à l'économie pensez par
exemple à la médecine et à l'industrie
agroalimentaire ou encore à la
climatologie et à l'industrie pétrolière
mais bon grâce à égal bresse les
économistes peuvent rentrer dans le
droit chemin
si vous avez aimé la vidéo mettez lui un
pouce bleus et abonnez-vous à la chaîne
pour être prévenu de la sortie de la
suivante pour lire ma synthèse de ce
petit livre les mensonges de l'économie
de john kenneth galbraith sur le site
milliers de culture générale voir pour
lui a laissé directement tous les liens
sont dans la description
n'hésitez pas non plus à laisser des
commentaires
pour recevoir les dernières idées de
culture générale synthétisée dans le
format le plus clair possible
vous pouvez vous inscrire à la
newsletter en laissant votre adresse
email sur le site
je suis romain et vous étiez sur mille
idées de culture générale rappelez vous
que vous n'avez pas besoin de vous
prendre la tête pour vous intéresser au
meilleur de la pensée
[Musique]